بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
والحمد لله رب العالمين
والصلاه والسلام على اشرف الخلق والمرسلين
وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين
اصحاب الجلاله
والفخامه والسموم معالم امين العام لجامعه
الدول العربيه
اتوجه اولا
في هذه الكلمه الموجزه
باسماع برات التهنئه
الى اخي
حضره خادم الحرمين الشريفين
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال سعود ملك
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه
والى صاحب السمو الملكي
الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال
سعود
ولي العهد
ورئيس مجلس الوزراء
مبتهلا الى الله
ان توفق اعمالنا وان تسدد خطانا في جمع
الكلمه
ووحده الصف
وانها لمناسبه ايضا في هذا المقام
لتوجيه الشكر الى اخي فخامه الرئيس عبد
المجيد تبون
رئيس الجمهوريه الجزائريه الديمقراطيه
الشعبيه الشقيقه
على مدار رئاسته للقمه
بروحا عاليه من المسؤوليه في لم الشمل
والحمد لله تعالى
ان تم لم الشمل
كما اتوجهوا بالشكر ايضا
الى معالي السيد احمد ابو الغيط اميمي عام
جامعه الدول العربيه
والى اعظضه على الجهود التي يبذرونها
بدون انقطاع
لتعزيز العلاقات بين
دولنا
وبين
المنظمات
الدوليه الاخرى
ايها الكريم
ان العالم
بصدد التشكل من جديد
بعد ان تشكل منذ نهايه القرن التاسع عشر
ودفر ودفع شعبنا العربي
في كل ارجاء وطننا العربي
الثمن باهظا
من اجل الحريه
والانعتاق والاستقلال
وما زرع اشقائنا في فلسطين
يقدمون كل يوما تقريبا
جحافر الشهداء
والجرحى
للتحرر من نير الاحتلال الصهيوني البغيض
هذا فضلا عن الاف الاف اللاجئين الذين لا
يسالون يعيشون في المخيمات
فما ان للانسانيه جماعه
ان تضع حدا لهذه المظلمه
المسلطه على شعبنا في فلسطين في ظل صمت
مريب
لعديد العواصم
ان هذا العالم
الذي هو بصدد التشكل اليوم
لا يجب ان يتشكل مجددا على حساب امتنا
وعلى مقدرات شعبنا
بل نريد ان نكون شركاء على قدم المساواه
مع من يريدون ترتيبه من جديد
فاذا كانت العولمه
التي ظهرت في بدايه السنوات التسعين
ذكرت هذه العولمه قد بلغت مداها
وانقلبت على عاقبيها
فاننا نرفض ان نكون مره اخرى
ضحايا
لنظاما
عالميا جديد لا نشارك في ارسائه وفي
ترتيبه
وتونس
ثابته على مواقفها
ثابته اولا على استقلال قرارها الوطني
ثابته ايضا على عدم الانخراط في اي تحالف
ضد اخر كما ينص على ذلك دستورها
وشعبها مصر على مبدا المساواه بين الدول
كما تنص على ذلك عديد المواثيق والصكوك
الدوليه
ان التحديات
التي نواجهها كبيره
ولا شك اننا نشترك في نفس الاراده من اجل
رفعها وتخطيها
واولى هذه التحديات
وليست اقلها على الاطلاق
هو الحفاظ على دولنا
لان هناك من يعمل على اسقاطها حتى تغيب
المؤسسات
وتعم الفوضى
بالاقتتالات الداخليه
ورحمه الله تعالى
على عوده سوريا
على عوده الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه الى
احضان جامعه الدول العربيه
بعد ان تم احباط المؤامره التي كانت تهدف
الى تفتيتها وتقسيمها
ودفع الشعب العربي السوري
الثمن غاليا حتى تبقى سوريا دوله واحده
كما ان ارادتنا هي ذاتها حتى تبقى ليبيا
دوله موحده ويحسم الشعب الليبي امره بنفسه
عن طريق الانتخابات ويعم الامن كل شبر من
اراضيها
ونفس الاداره الاراده عفوا تحدونه
حتى يسترجع اليمن السعيد سعادته بوحده
شعبه وبالقضاء على كل اسباب الفرقه
والانقسام
نفس الامل يختونه بان يتوقف سفك الدماء
بالسودان الذي قسموه الى الشطرين في
ديسمبر من سنه 2000 فلا نريد سودانا ثالثا
او رابعا اثر هذه الحرب الماساه
وثاني هذه التحديات وليست اقلها حتى وان
وردت بعض التحدي الاول في المقام الثاني
هو الحفاظ على السلم الاهليه
والسلم لن تتحقق الا بالحلول الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه
النابعه من اراده الشعب
فبدون القضاء على الفقر وبدون عداله
اجتماعيه لن يتحقق الاستقرار السياسي
المرشود
وانعدام الاستقرار لن يؤثر فقط على
اوطاننا بل سيؤثر حتما على كل الدول
ومن التحديات ايضا ولا يتسع المجال لذكرها
كلها التحدي الثقافي
فبدون ثقافه وبدون تعليم سليبين ونشر قيم
التسامح والتعايش والاعتزاز
بالانتماء الى امتنا لا يمكن ان نحسن
مجتمعاتنا ضد من يتربص بتفكيكها كتربسه
بتفكيك الدول وتقسيمها
ولدينا
من الامكانيات مجتمعين ما يكفي
لتحقيق ما نشترك بالتاكيد في العزم على
تحقيقه وتجسيده في اسرى اوقات بعيدا عن اي
وصفات يريدون املائها علينا من الخارج
فنحن دعاه سلما وسلام ونحن دعاه عدل وحريه
لامتنا
وللامسانيه جمعاء ولا نريد ان تتكرر
الماسي او تستمر كما كانت في الماضي لان
التاريخ
لا خير فيه ان كان سيعيد ما قد ولى وانقضى
وشكرا على الاصغاء والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله وبركاته
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات